no I refuse well it tastes like sherbert
but kind of look like a smoothie right
now is it's like Generic berry I don't
like like if you were to dip fruit into
chocolate with no nutritional value like
if I'm gonna do this I'm gonna eat the
fruit and not gain ten pounds
[Music]
there's some high expectations there god
this is cookie dough flavored cream a
really terrible fake cookie oppa taste
everything I dream does my cookie dough
I'm underwhelmed the banana is
overwhelming ah bad there are a lot of
flavors happening in my mouth right now
there's this is chaos I like it no it's
the fake strawberry that's really awful
dial it down Oreo the only thing that
watermelon tree makes with is vodka this
looks like playdough this is adorable
it tastes like watermelon Jolly Rancher
wait it does taste like watermelon not
bad yeah go ahead
I know I taste just like a mini male on
Dave mm-hmm you know this is gross oh
the end of this is so sugary and why me
and salts you this is like the food
equivalent of a lie Marita there's like
a mojito you're like oh this smells like
you threw up after eating fruit okay
smells like kool-aid oh I don't like
that it's like a pixie stick it's like
somebody dipped a packet of pre-made
drink into like the Oreo cream but if
sugar overload is like oh I mean it is
really accurate Oh crazy
now this I'm excited for feel like I
just walked into Starbucks cuz I pumpkin
pie great football it's kind of like
ginger snappy it's a good mix of flavors
having the cookie there is like the
crust to the pumpkin pie so I'm pretty
good I would have this after
Thanksgiving for sure can i Cookie
Monster these Oreos
[Laughter]
[Music]